لسان الرئيس الامريكي ينزلق مجددا ويعود
الى نحو 100 عام تقريبا في زله لسان جو
بايدن الاخيره فان نانسي بيلوسي رئيسه
مجلس النواب الامريكي السابقه ساعدت في
انقاذ الاقتصاد في فتره الكساد الكبير اي
في عام 1929
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بحسبه بسيطه
حينها لم تولد بعد
زله تلقفها مغردون وعلقوا عليها بطريقتهم
فهذا التعليق يذكر ان بيلوسي ولدت في
نهايه الكساد الكبيره وهنا اعتبرت هفوه
بايدن افضل مجامله لامراه
سخريه لم تتوقف عند حدود السوشيال ميديا
بل تعدتها الى الفضائيات
الزله الاخيره ليست الوحيده اذ سجلت لي
بايدن العديد منها في مره سابقه وربما لم
تكون الاخيره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات